notre invité et jimmy jean économiste en
chef et stratège chez desjardins bonsoir
alors hausse attendue on disait mais un
ton quand même de la banque du canada
franchement plus agressif c'est quoi le
message de la banque pour vous
aujourd'hui
le mandat de la banque centrale c'est de
rendre une inflation stable prévisible
et un bon niveau en ce moment les
inflations du ni stable ni prévisible ni
un bon niveau donc activement à ce qu'on
dit en ce moment c'est que l'inflation
continue de dépasser même des
anticipations qui sont constamment
révisées à la hausse et on a vu johnny
allen cette semaine et effectuer le même
constat à quel point on s'est trompé sur
l'inflation donc dans une environnement
d'inflation aussi
imprévisible la banque du canada nos
poches chouette d'avertir d'être honnête
avec les ménages les entreprises les
investisseurs que plus doit être fait
pour vraiment ramener cette inflation là
sous contrôle et que la banque du canada
devra être prête à faire les gestes
nécessaires donc je pense que c'était le
ton à avoir dans le contexte actuel
parfait la banque du canada dit
aujourd'hui que le risque d'une
inflation élevée sans racine s'est accru
et l'inflation devrait encore monter à
court terme avant de commencer à
diminuer donc l'inflation va continuer
encore augmenter dans les prochains mois
nous dit la banque centrale est tout à
fait parce que les dernières données
qu'on a sous la main sont celles d'avril
or on sait qu est-ce que c'est pas ça
mais forte augmentation des prix de
l'essence continue voire la dépression
dans les prix des aliments donc ça se
poursuit le pétrole qui a touché les 120
dollars donc les pressions sont
certainement lors il ya des enjeux des
sanctions les tensions géopolitiques qui
reste très importante donc c'est très
difficile à court terme de pouvoir
prétendre que l'inflation est sur le
point de descendre donc c'est pour ça
qu'on reste assez prudent là dessus on
s'attend quand même à ce que ça se
stabilise au cours des prochains mois
mais pour l'instant la visibilité là
dessus et pas au rendez vous donc à ce
titre là c'est pour ça que la banque du
canada un regard de la politique
monétaire à une 58 on augmente et où on
le fait de manière très rapidement on
reste très en dessous du niveau neutre
qui ferait en sorte que on arrêterait de
stimuler l'économie en ce moment même à
une cinquante on continue de stimuler
l'économie exact et l'avant dit aussi
que le conseil de direction juge encore
que les taux d'intérêt vont devoir
augmenter encore davantage et il le
conseil de direction est prêt à agir
avec plus de force s'il le faut plus de
force ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
c'est possible qu'on doive aller au
dessus du tourneur donc nous on s'attend
à ce que la banque du canada s'arrête à
2,25 dont la prochaine hausse de taux en
juillet devrait être de 50 points de
base et on s'attend à ce qu'il y ait une
autre de 25 points de base en septembre
à ce moment là on devrait avoir les
effets que commence à transparaître
notamment dans le marché immobilier en
une économie qui est très très sensible
aux taux d'intérêts étant donné
l'endettement des ménages et ça ça
devrait commencer à avoir un effet de
ralentissement à ce moment là la banque
du canada devrait se sentir confortable
de d'entreprendre une certaine pause
analyser l'impact des mesures
entreprises jusqu'à maintenant par
contre si c'est pas le cas si on
continue voire dépression entre autres
provenant des tensions géopolitiques des
chaînes d'approvisionnement
à ce moment là ce qu'on dit c'est que
peut-être qu'il va falloir aller encore
un peu plus haut ramener ça peut-être à
3% donc c'est un peu ce qu'on dit je
pense que l'idée d'une heure aux de 75
points de base au début on avait ouvert
la porte à la suite de ça messieurs
macklem avait été un petit peu plus
prudent là dessus j'ai l'impression que
plus on augmente les taux plus le niveau
s'approche de la neutralité ça va être
plus difficile d'avoir des hausses de 75
points de base mais on va être en
revanche prêt à aller un petit peu plus
haut est-ce que après deux années de
pandémie les canadiens semblent quand
même décidé à voyager et à dépenser en
ce moment est-ce que vous pensez que on
va passer à travers ce en récession pour
l'instant on regarde les finances des
ménages le marché de l'emploi
ça va très bien on a un taux de chômage
à un niveau record de faiblesse au
québec au canada les salaires commencent
à voir des signes plus probant là dessus
les ménages les travailleurs vont
négocier pour capable de protéger leur
pouvoir d'achat il ya encore des
liquidités qui
qui reste même si une partie qui a été
érodée par l'inflation mais on n'a pas
vu les ménages vraiment piger dans leur
épargne accumulée au complet donc le
portrait pour les prochains mois restent
encore assez positif et on sait que
qu'est ce qui détermine son 120
récessions c'est si la consommation en
autres en contraction donc pour
l'instant on voit pas sa sueur venir
l'année prochaine quand l'effet des taux
va avoir plus de mordant c'est là que la
question va plus se pose la banque dit
que la demande reste excédentaire
présentement et que l'offre est toujours
perturbée donc on est comme dans une
espèce de grand déséquilibre entre
l'offre et la demande tout à fait tout à
fait et six coups au début de l'année on
espérait voir une amélioration au niveau
des chaînes d'approvisionnement au
niveau des prix des matières premières
on a vu linverse étant donné dé nouveau
choc inattendu qui se sont ajoutés avec
l'ukraine avec les confinements à chine
donc on est constamment en train
d'ajouter des chocs et on dirait qu'on
voit pas la fin c'est ce qui fait en
sorte que l'offre n'arrive pas vraiment
à se rétablir c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
dit pour entre autres pour les
entreprises l'investissement vont être
critiques parce que l'investissement ces
vecteurs de productivité productive sa
vision de l'augmentation de la capacité
de l'offre et c'est vraiment l'antidote
à l'inflation donc il ya des moyens de
se prémunir à ça ça passe par
l'investissement plus vigoureux analyse
très éclairante merci beaucoup de jeunes
gens d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]